you remember the back flips used to do
let's do the flip that was so close you
know there have been a lot of great
comedy teams in movie history but maybe
just maybe we found the next great one
at least Kevin Hart Dwayne Johnson
believed there the next great comedy
team you were the coolest kid in high
school used to be in Central
Intelligence dewayne's chubby geek
turned chiselled CIA agent teams up with
Kevin's popular kid turned accountant at
their high school reunion - what else
save the wall you ready no sweet let's
go no I said no you guys now come to the
biggest dog round the planet who's more
popular in high school in real life 100%
me a hundred percent of the most popular
kid in high school I wasn't the cool guy
for being funny made me include the true
stories effect look it up well look I
got a say look I can't argue with that
right he was funny in high school cool
in high school but I did the truth it
there's the truth how was my party
because you know this voice right now
what you do I worked out six hours a day
every day for the last 20 years straight
this is an important question okay cuz I
lose theater
oh now let's talk about it let's get
involved with and the question is he
gets up at five six o'clock in the
morning he's crazy he's a maniac but I
mean I gotta go here's the thing here's
a thank ya I'm a better when it comes to
working out I left the gym I love
everybody in it I am very much in shape
I'm especially
you know looking at my body is
definitely it's definitely something
that she began ago we were like I want
that yeah it's what people think
now as you had the experience of working
together would you want to work with him
they can never get me what about the
words again right yes you already
started what are you talking about where
we've all read where the ninth inning
we're in the process yes what they
didn't say is that they're already
shooting a remake of the Robin Williams
movie Jumanji and that should be out
next year so they're together they're
staying together